so some of you in here might be
wondering that i look nothing like my
picture
in the app uh i just had someone come
approach me about that i tried to get
ryan who happens to be my husband to do
this talk for me i was like look the app
says you're going to be the one doing
the talk
he didn't buy it though so you're you
get to look at me instead
so i'm going to talk about fractals
today and i'm going to try to hopefully
make them practical for you
but to start i'm going to tell a story
about a friend of mine
her name was jen we went to high school
together and then we went off to
different colleges and so i hadn't seen
her in a while
when i decided to visit her one summer
and i go into her apartment and she has
all these wonderful pictures of fractals
and posters all over her
apartment she had mandelbrot set julia
set
all all beautiful things and i got
really excited because she'd never
really been into math
i it was really surprising we'd known
each other for years and i just never
really thought she was that into math
and so i said
wow jen i didn't know you like fractals
and she gave me a very
very blank stare and she said what are
you talking about
and so while those posters you have you
know you have all these fractals on your
on your walls and
she said what is that so i said oh okay
you know and to be honest i i kind of
thought
that maybe she knew what they were
because you know we were old enough that
uh you know jurassic park had come out
recently and everybody got really
excited about chaos theory
because of jeff goldblum's character and
so i thought well maybe she went out and
she read a book because
we didn't have wikipedia back then
but but no she just went to the store
and she bought them because they were
really
pretty and so i had to sat down i had to
sit down and kind of walk her through
what these were and how they worked and
when i was all done
she thanked me and said that now she
loved the posters even more
which is great because otherwise we
couldn't have stayed friends
it would have been over at that moment
because i am and always have been a math
geek in fact the only reason i got into
computer science was it was the one
degree where i was guaranteed a job and
i could do math most of the time
this is a picture of me in middle school
i was on the math team so that meant
that i like to get up on saturday
mornings
at 7 00 am to ride a bus for an hour
to go to some rural school to take a
math test
for fun
and so i had read about fractals in this
wonderful book
chaos making a new science by james
gleek and to be honest
i will admit that that was inspired by
jurassic park so it did trigger me to go
do this
it inspired me so much that i took the
time to write my very first program for
fun
i did uh the logistic map in c plus
logistic map which i have up here is one
of the simplest equations you can
represent from chaos theory which is
that
basically you kind of iterate over a
really simple function
and you watch the behavior as you change
different values of it and as you change
those values and you iterate you get to
see really chaotic behaviors
represented by this image and so i took
the time i i
really basic plain old c plus program
and just spit it out i was so excited i
showed it to my calculus teacher and he
was excited too it was great
ever since that moment i wanted an
excuse to use fractals because i just
loved the idea of these really
simple equations making these complex
and sometimes
very beautiful things and so i thought
one day maybe
one day i'll get an opportunity to use
them and then i went through my whole
college degree and got my first job and
kind of gave up a little hope until
i got to work with navigation systems
so navigation systems are interesting
because they deal with geographic data
which is by nature multiple dimensions
we always have a latitude and a
longitude
sometimes we go to three dimensions
because sometimes we care about
elevation
or even something more abstract like
sometimes we care about how
roads are layered on top of each other
and as part of our jobs in dealing with
that kind of data is that we're
constantly trying to find ways
to squeeze those multiple dimensions
into one because that makes our lives
easier we don't have to reason about all
these different values we can just
reason about the one value that we've
formed out of them
and so in essence we're just constantly
looking for some sort of function
that will take our two values or if it's
many values in a
much more dimensional world and just
kind of map it on to a single
value that represents the full semantics
of the multi-dimensional data that we
are playing with
and once we do that we can very easily
solve the types of problems that come up
in multi-dimensional worlds like a range
query
which asks what subset of the data is in
within the range of these values
uh in geographic systems that usually
forms kind of a box so we're trying to
figure out what things
fit in this box or if it's more
elaborate it might be a polygon
we might be looking for things that are
near other things so you know a point
in the map you know what other items are
near that point what is the closest
police station or the closest fast food
restaurant
and then we can generalize that even
more and say we care more than about
just one thing we want the 10 things or
the 20 things that are closest to this
item in the data
and the funny thing is that k nearest is
kind of become a loaded term
a little bit and there's multiple
versions of the problem and i find that
when i talk about k-nearest from my
understanding of it which just comes
from this
multi-dimensional search space i often
find people who are really into machine
learning and clustering and they're like
you mean the clustering algorithm
that's one form of it that's not the
only form
in fact uh donald knuth talked about uh
nearest neighbor
in the art of computer programming and
he renamed it the post office problem
because the idea was uh you have a house
and need to figure out what
post office to assign that house to so
that term has been around for a while
but it's gotten a lot of traction lately
with clustering
and so we could solve this with brute
force we could
we could take the time and we could
basically look at all the
points in the data set and we could come
up with some function that represents
euclidean distance and we could just
basically look and see you know what's
the closest thing based on that
distance measure but that doesn't sound
like fun
and i got into math and i got into
computer science because i thought it
was fun
so i want to do better than that also
usually in any system we work with we're
dealing with some sort of constraint you
know we don't have all the power in the
world we don't have all the memory in
the world
and so we want to be a little more
clever we want to find a way to optimize
to use some sort of data structure or
algorithm that's going to make this
easier on us
and usually most of those data
structures or algorithms require that we
have
some way to order the data we may have
to sort it
we may just have to bucket it but
there's got to be something inherent to
how the data is ordered so we can work
with that data structure
and ordering usually requires a
comparison
we have to find one way of knowing that
something should come before something
else
for that to work and i would argue that
that comparison function
is actually that mapping of those
dimensions into a single one
and what i mean by that is that well let
me get to that a minute so
this is a typical comparison function we
might see or write
when we're dealing with multiple fields
i'm sure a lot of people in this room
this is julia code maybe not this exact
form of it but a lot of people in this
room have written something that looked
like this at one point in their careers
hopefully early on they're not doing it
anymore but where you basically had a
object of some sort or a type of some
sort that had multiple members in it and
you needed to compare them
and so you had to pick one field to test
for equality
and only if that is equal do you look at
the other fields and you progress on
down
and that's how you order them
that has a problem and that problem is
that when we deal with
multi-dimensionals
multi-dimensional data and we have these
two fields it doesn't always work out
right
for example right now we're here we're
in the peabody opera house this
is the location of this place
and if i did that approach i would find
this long john silvers as the closest
fast food restaurant
doesn't look bad except
that's where it is and if you're
geographically challenged and you don't
believe me
we are here in saint louis
and you draw a straight line across the
map
you end up in sacramento california so
that's why that happens
so i'm going to visualize some things as
i talk through
what we really should be doing and i'm
very much a visual person i always draw
pictures
if you're ever in a meeting with me um
i'll just like stop and get up and just
drawing on the whiteboard because i have
to see things in order to understand
them and so
i'm going to assume other people in the
room are like me and i'm just going to
use lots and lots of pictures in this so
one of the visualizations going to start
out with is this grid
it's two dimensions four possible values
on each side very simple idea and i'm
just going to talk through
the order in which you would hit cells
and how you would behave
in this kind of system using different
approaches for ordering the data
so this is my origin and let's say i
wanted to find all things close to this
the approach that we saw the comparison
function that basically checks for
equality and then only then looks at
other fields
would basically do something like this
where as long as something was in a
column
it would be considered close if you had
to jump a column and be considered far
away
now we can look in this and we can know
this isn't what we want
but that approach does work sometimes
and actually a lot of the time that's
why we always probably spend a lot of
time running code that looks like that
because it works
most the time these are cases where it
works really well
if you are looking for a particular
office in an
office complex you might start with
building and then you might have floor
and then aisle and then door if you have
an address
it's okay to start with country and then
narrow it down to
state or province or whatever the
terminology is based on the area
and then go to city and then to street
and then to street number
and the same thing if we were you know
all going to go to a game at the stadium
it'd be okay if we looked at section
first and made sure that they were
equivalent on section
before we looked at row and looked at
number
and this the reason why this works is
because the data has a natural priority
it's just inherent to it and so we can
leverage that priority and if we're
smart we'll actually do the comparison
in an order that leverages that as well
and so this is again julia code that
kind of shows the stadium example just
to illustrate it
if we were looking for four seats
together this would find it for us this
this would work
now i talked a lot about how ultimately
we're trying to do this
mapping of multi-dimensions into a
single value and so i want to prove to
you that those comparison functions do
that
and what i like to think about is that
that comparison function tells us the
order in which the items will be visited
and that order in which those items will
be visited
can be that magic value for us so it can
be that single value
so basically z becomes the position in
the ordering
i'm also going to argue that doing this
based approach
is a shortcut for concatenating all of
the bits
of the members into a single number
and so that would look like this if we
had x and y values nine and three
we have you know two bit representations
when we use that type of comparison
in order to order the data we end up
with one big number
that represents if we just smush them
two together and in this case it'd be
147.
so back to that grid i said i was going
to use as a way to visualize this if we
watched
how we would move through the data if we
were ordering it because again i'm
saying that ordering is actually that
magic number
we would move through it like this
so what shape did that make well that
made a nice little n
it looks just like an n and that's in
that simple
simple picture right there if we bring
that to a bigger bigger
shape like we just did we could walk
through it again this is the order they
would hit
and now we have a bunch of ends just
snuggled up against each other
but there's a problem and that ends have
these big jumps
and that means that in this kind of
approach we have things that aren't
really close together
that we're claiming are close together
because the ordering says they are and
that's why we have the sacramento
problem
we have another problem as well which is
as we scale up the model
it doesn't match anymore the the that
number for things
changes as we make a bigger grid and so
that's not very helpful
and so it has some inconsistency as it
scales that kind of approach
so can we do better well i hope so
because that's what i'm supposed to tell
you about
first i have to ask what do we want like
what's important to us because chances
are we're going to make some trade-offs
that's most of what we do
in engineering is we make some sort of
trade-off and so in this case we're
gonna have to make some but first we
have to know what we really care about
what i really care about the fact that
things that are far away
aren't considered close in our approach
because that's what's really going to
annoy me is having to to go far out of
my
way to find something when there was
something closer to me and the system
just didn't find it
and i call that the i do not drive to
sacramento for fast food rule
so what we want from a picture
standpoint behavior more like this
so if it's only one unit away in any
direction it's close if it's two units
then it's a little farther and on back
and that doesn't matter for which point
is the search point it should always
work no matter which point we pick
and you're probably thinking that's
obvious why'd she even say that the
reason i say that is
because i used to ask this as an
interview question
when i would interview new engineers
experienced early career doesn't matter
use this as an interview question it's a
great conversation about how they
approach technical problems
and i would find the number of
candidates both experienced
and early career that would propose to
me that they would just calculate all
the distances and then sort the data by
that and then do a binary search was
was quite high and so i'd have to talk
through in the interview how well that
doesn't actually work because when i
change the origin you have to resort all
the lists
and from that standpoint we're just back
to brute force right like that's not
that's not any better so what's another
idea
well concatenating the bits was silly
could we interleave them so could we
take one bit from each dimension
and start appending and building a
number that way is that an idea
you know is that foolish is that naive
is that awesome you know
we're going to find out of course so it
would look like this so we have our 9
and 3 example again
and we have the two numbers we just work
through and this would work no matter
how many dimensions you have you can do
it three or four you just
keep picking bits off you do have to
understand that your number is going to
grow if you started with the two 32-bit
numbers then you're going to need a
64-bit number and keep rolling on up as
you do this
and the new ordering would be 135 for
that coordinate um
based on this new approach and you know
julia code pretty simple to work with
i've done a lot of bit operations in my
career for whatever reason and so this i
read this and it's obvious to me right
away but if you haven't done a lot of
bit operations good for you
it's not always fun to do a lot of bit
manipulation
but that's basically this is just doing
the interleaving of the data
and this is what our grid would look
like now so
the numbers indicate the order that we'd
hit them and then i had the bit
representations for what would be a two
by two
um two bit by two bit representation
and we can walk through it
and just kind of see how it hits
and there we go so that looked better
right as we were watching it move
through it looked a little better
and hey it made a z different different
letter
oddly enough a lot of things i do today
are going to look like letters
and if we look at it in a bigger picture
we'd actually have z's
that connect to z's that connect to z's
and then kind of make
another z and then i just want to see
what it looks like bigger so
a z z connect disease and that's the
picture
and so the inner leaf doesn't actually
look that bad now right maybe it's
leaning towards the awesome
part not so much foolish or naive um and
so we really should call it give it a
good name
and so we could call it z order that's
why a lot of people call this because of
all the z's
um we could go one step further and call
it by its real name which would be
better which is morton
uh because you know you want to give the
guy who discovered it some credit
and the great thing about this approach
the great thing about morton is that you
don't
even have to do the work of interleaving
the bits just
like the comparison functions we write
all the time those boilerplate ones
are a shortcut for bit concatenation
because we didn't have to concatenate
the bits
there are shortcuts for the morton-based
approach as well where
basically all you have to do is test the
most significant bit of each dimension
and can just move on down until you find
the first difference
and then you can kind of short circuit
out of the process
and it's more efficient
when i remove all the z's and we look at
the places where we had to kind of
stitch them together we had to connect
them
we've got these green lines left over
and some of them probably look bad
especially that one in the middle it
makes a huge jump
and when we have those huge jumps what
that means is that we have something in
our data
that looks close together but really
isn't
that's because they from the curve
standpoint their distance is only one
because they're only one ordering
away from each other but in the grid
they're actually much much further apart
as we can
see and so
some things that are close in space also
seem far in this approach we don't have
the green lines to really show that off
but i can
kind of point out two points those
things are really only one unit away
but in this model they look very far
away in fact if you count up the order i
think they're about 22
positions away and so if you're driving
your car and you're running out of gas
and you're trying to find the nearest
gas station you might get pretty pissed
because the system is going to tell you
to drive
right by that one and go to one that's a
little further away from you
however the overall ordering is good um
so if you really cared about that the
first and last item were really kind of
completely opposite each other um this
approach would would actually work quite
well for you because they are
so maybe there's something inherently
wrong with the z we didn't like the n
maybe the z is problematic too so let's
try a different shape
let's try this so that's an upside down
u
as what i'm calling it uh if we look at
the coordinates that we're passing
through in terms of order we go from
0 zero and then we go to zero one
and then one one and then one zero
and if you're used to looking at a lot
of bits or if you have a background and
maybe some electrical engineering
you might notice that it's only one bit
flipping
as we move through the shape and there's
a name for that
it's called gray code a grey code is a
numbering system that was designed with
that in mind
binary is a great numbering system it's
easy to understand at least for the
people in this room
others maybe not so much uh but it is
hard from a standpoint of sort of
electrical engineering because you're
always having to move a whole bunch of
bits at once and back in the old days
there was a lot of concern about that
being error prone
so they came up this idea of
what if we could have an approach that
basically only flipped one bit
as you're moving through the numbering
system the most well-known way to
calculate a grade code is this code
which basically says return an xord with
half of itself
and that will give you a really easy
quick gray code that will have the
behavior you want
in the ordering you want and just to
kind of show how that works
here's 0 through 15 in that gray code
and you can watch the numbering
the number representations are not what
we're used to but as we move through it
only really one bit is ever flipping
and that's kind of what we might want to
apply here because we have this system
and when we
move and order the items we only really
want to shift by a little bit because we
want to maintain
that proximity maintain that locality in
the distance so
maybe we can leverage this and so maybe
maybe next idea we say okay we take a
gray code
and we do the bit interleaving because
we liked that it just wasn't good enough
and let's just throw this
stuff together and see what happens so
let's see what happens
okay so that looks a little weird if we
draw what was happening i was doing this
so that
that is bad that is very bad um in fact
let's never do that again
that was a horrible horrible idea forget
i ever showed it to you
um and please just just don't do it
the shape wasn't bad though um the shape
was okay the problem was how we stitched
it together
so let's look at another way to stitch
this together
so we're gonna start with the bigger
space because obviously the the simple
one's really easy
and i'm just gonna kind of stick them on
there and rotate them a little bit
so there goes there that goes there goes
there
hey not bad so let's look at it bigger
i'll stick one there i'll stick one
there stick one there
stick one there i'll stitch them
together
not bad either right
uh so the code to do this is not pretty
i'm not going to pretend right now that
it's easy by any means
we have to figure out when to rotate
things and and that's not always an easy
decision because we're
our brains don't usually think like that
and then we have to
do some of that grey code magic as well
as doing some of the bit interleaving at
the same time and
wait it's not pretty again it's it's not
easy to understand code but it's it's
small
um and if i take it and i kind of make
bigger and bigger grids so i used
gadfly for this so i could take the
julia code and kind of generate a bigger
one and see what it looks like
and so i could kind of see this
wonderful as i go up it just keeps
filling that space it just keeps
kind of tightly turning and and doing a
really good job of ordering everything
so this is not terribly elegant nor easy
to understand
but it works so it's it's better than
the other two approaches we've seen
and i can show that it works because i
remove the shapes and this is where we
stitch things together and every time we
stitch things together we've only really
moved
one unit in the grid so we're not having
these big jumps and data
and that means that things that are
close in the curve are also close in
space
where we were able to to do that and and
have that work out
unfortunately some things that are close
in the space
are not close in the curve we saw that
with the z
order as well with the morton but that's
still here um
and then we didn't really get that
absolute ordering
um the thing that is first and the thing
that lasts aren't really
the first the farthest apart things but
but overall
it worked pretty well it got us what we
needed
so some of you are disappointed right
now i'm sure i
my talk was practical fractals and i
just bored you with bit operations for
you know the last uh we're going on 25
minutes
well i want to prove to you that these
are actually fractals um these are
they're not fractals like we like to
think about uh you know when we think of
fractals we think of the mandelbrot set
we think of this
part of the julius set these beautiful
pictures that ended up being posters on
my friend's
apartment room walls or we maybe we
think of these shapes
actually these are some of my favorite
fractals the the weird ones that are
kind of counter-intuitive and how they
manipulate space
this one is a pyramid that you you
subtract out pyramids and you keep doing
that until eventually your pyramids
empty even though it's a solid which is
just
really cool or we think of
a lot of times the mandelbrot set which
is the most famous one and i used gadfly
again to
to generate that and julia for fun
well let's look at the properties these
things i don't think pretty
is a property of a fractal nor do i
think cool is one either so we have to
be a little more rigid than that
so the first important thing is that
they have to be self-similar
you have to kind of see that recursion
play out as you're looking at them
they you also have to be nowhere
differentiable that's that's another
requirement of it
um you know we can't find a line tangent
to the curve at any point
and then a little more kind of weird is
that you have to have this hausdorff
dimension that's greater than your
topological dimension
whereas topological dimension is how we
think
of dimensions you know we think of lines
and
and points and solids and and polygons
is all having a certain dimension no
matter what they look like
the other dimension the house dwarf is
more kind of something that talks about
how things really behave
independent of their structure
so these things are self-similar i we
saw that as we were building them up you
know we started with the z
for the simplest case and then we put
the z's together in a shape of a z
and we can keep doing that on and on and
up in bigger and bigger spaces
same thing with the hilbert which is the
name for it
is that we started with that u and then
we connected them to make a u
and then we connected those to make a u
so so hopefully you agree with me at
this point that there is that
self-similarity
in these things they are also
nowhere differentiable um
this is an animation i got it off of
wikipedia it's great
that shows you that as you do more and
more
iterations of these of these curves they
actually fill the space
and in order to fill the space that's
what it means by it went white it's not
actually just that the screen went bad
it's like it filled the space
with the curve in order to spill the
space they have to turn
so tightly that you lose the ability to
find a line tangent to them so that's
that's kind of cool
coming from matthew i love that
and then they do have that behavior and
that their topological dimension doesn't
actually match
how they behave because these things are
lines
um which should be you know
one-dimensional and yet
as we progress in the iterations and we
implement them they actually
fill a two-minutial space their house
dwarf dimensions actually is two
they're considered two
so the funny thing is is that these
things
were discovered a long long time ago
this is not really cutting edge
technology
the hilbert curve which is the one that
looks like the little use was discovered
in 1891 by david hilbert
he wasn't really trying to solve any
sort of geographic problem of course he
didn't know that
garmin would someday come into existence
but what he was doing
is that he and another man named
giuseppe piano were playing with the
idea
of could you take a unit square which is
you know just like a unit circle except
it's square
and if you had a curve or a continuous
function
could you fill it and they were kind of
playing with like countability and
cardinality and different you know
counter-intuitive behaviors of things
and no one really believed at the time
you could do this
and giuseppe piano proved that you could
and he found the first space-filling
curve
his mistake was that when he wrote his
paper he didn't draw any pictures of it
so back to things being visual or is
important um
and so what happened is that david
hilberg came after him
and documented the hilbert curve and he
got a lot of publicity because it was
this really cool picture
in the middle of the paper
now mandelbra who is the father of the
term
fractal didn't coin into the mid 70s
and so these men had discovered fractals
before we even knew what to call them
even morton found it before fractals
were a name he found the morton curve in
1966
he was trying to solve a problem of
geographic data he had some files on a
file system that he wanted to sync
sequence based on their geographic
location and he needed a way to do that
and he came up with the idea of
interleaving the bits and
and that's how we got the morton curve
and i apologize i couldn't find a
picture of him
i guess you know not all computer
science tests are that famous but
so hopefully i've convinced you that
they are fractals
now i have to convince you that they're
practical
so we write a lot of code like this as
i've said before
and when we're trying to solve with this
multi-dimensional problems
and this works for some cases but
there's a lot of cases where it doesn't
work
but we need some sort of comparison
function because we need to be able to
take our data and figure out how to
shove it into some sort of structure
that we're already familiar with
and those structures usually require
some way to compare it
so we can actually use that number now
that we've done that mapping of our
multiple dimensions into a new number
which is the hilbert number or if you
wanted to use more than the morton
number
and you can use that as your comparison
function as your means to
order the data
and once you do that you can get back to
the very simple algorithms
that you already know and love like
binary search
or a binary search tree or skip lists i
put archery up there because hilbert has
been used to optimize
our trees as well but any kind of data
structure that you could traditionally
search
using some sort of comparison based
function you can now
work with multiple dimensions using one
of these these approaches
i we did a lot of binary just plain old
binary search with this um where i
where i worked and so just basically map
it all into one big array and and do the
search and it worked quite well
and so i also want to show you that it's
not just navigation systems that's the
obvious one because we can all wrap our
heads around you know that we have these
locations and
they have dimensions and we have to get
to them but there are other places that
multi-dimensional problems show up
and you know again in that space we're
just looking for a searchable index of
geographic features but there's other
searchable
indexes that we need somewhere
so image search is a good example we
could
use this as a means to search an image
for some sort of object within that
image
images in their nature are
two-dimensional you can also represent
them already as a single dimension but
if you wanted to
leverage the spatial locality of
something in that image you could use an
approach like this to do it
i actually did read an article of a guy
who was using this on
binary images meaning like executables
and things as a way of trying to reverse
engineer what's in
the image so he would go in and he would
look to figure out like if he saw some
patterns in blocks
in the file that he could kind of figure
out in that binary file this is what was
going on
a completely different type of image but
interesting nonetheless
another way it might show up would be
collision detection when we want to know
in some sort of space are two things
likely to be
in the same location and we want to do
something with them
or if you work for a company that has a
big big warehouse
and you have aisles and you have rows
and you have shelves
maybe you need to figure out how to
search within that warehouse based on
those three dimensions
and that leads to a quick and obvious
jump
to the idea of well maybe a data center
because data centers are really you know
warehouses full
of machines that we want to leverage
and i'm not the first person to have
this idea because as we learned this
morning no ideas are new
everyone's had all the ideas before and
so
if you've worked with slurm the simple
linux utility for resource management
and you go poking around in their source
code because it is open source
you will find hilbert.c
and they basically use hilbert they use
the hilbert curve
in order to make sure that jobs that
need to
be spatially local within the cluster
run together so they stick them all the
all the machines all the
nodes in the cluster in one big array
organized by hilbert order and then they
just kind of
try to find sections within that that
are close so that they can make sure the
jobs
run together
and so the thing that makes these this
great for these
problems is that they do kind of fit
that pattern of a grid and
not just a grid in two dimensions but we
could also go on to three dimensions
and so since they work great for grids
we have to figure out how do we identify
that the problem space we're working in
looks like a grid like we need to know
that we're dealing with a grid so we can
use these approaches
and basically i kind of think of a grid
is anything that has dense data with
multiple dimensions or keys or fields or
whatever name we want to give it
that have similar cardinality so we kind
of see roughly the same things
along different axes they could be
different values because they could be a
different scale but they
roughly the same number of different
types of values
now when i did these slides i did
everything in 2d
and that's because 2d is easier for us
to wrap our brains around
if i tried to do a bunch of
three-dimensional images you would
probably
not be able to follow them at all plus
the codes a lot simpler
and and 2d in fact if you ever do
try to take this approach and with some
code go out and look at some of the
generalizations versions of the
algorithm that allow it to work in
multiple dimensions because
it will be much much better for you than
using my
lovely hack together bit code and so to
show you that it works even in 3d here
is a 3d rendering of the morton curve
and then here's one of the hilbert curve
i do have this with me today and so
if you run into me later on i i will
show it to you
it's really awesome because um i got it
from a 3d print shop
and they the the plastic is kind of
flexible and so you can actually like
stretch it out and play with it
and when i when i got it the person was
showing me that a girl had it like as a
hair tie which was hilarious
and so you know feel free to stop me and
i'll show it to you today it's a little
small to show the room so that's why i'm
not bringing it out
of course we have to ask about when
doesn't this work whenever
nothing ever works perfectly all the
time and as we went through the
different examples i kind of showed that
there's some things that morton
did better when it's easier to
understand and there are things that
hilbert did better but both of them made
compromises
both of them had situations where it
wasn't perfect in terms of the ordering
well there are also situations when they
don't really work
for one if you have a mismatch
in your dimensions in terms of the
number of possible values
in fact hilbert and most implementations
of hilbert really assume kind of like
you have a power of two
so it works really well if you're
dealing with you know integer based
numbers you can
actually extend it to work in floats as
well but if you have something that
works in a power of two it works it
works really well
but if you have something like this and
of course it would probably be more than
eight it'd probably be like 80 000 but i
can't fit that on my screen
you wouldn't want to use this approach
because there's just too much mismatch
it also doesn't work uh when you have
the cursive dimensionality
uh the cursive dimensionality is a term
that's been thrown around a lot
especially more and more with data
analytics and data mining
this idea that you know some spaces
we're working in some problem spaces
have so many different features and so
many different dimensions
that the approaches that we take to work
with them kind of fall flat
because we don't have enough data to
justify the approach we're taking
usually you hear it from in terms of
machine learning like you need a bigger
training space because you have so many
dimensions
but the problem shows up anytime you're
working with multi-dimensional data that
if you have lots and lots and lots of
dimensions
the approaches you take to work with it
just start kind of degrading in terms of
how
valuable they are if you don't have lots
and lots of data
to go with it at the same time
so i wanted to kind of end with this
quote that i love
from mandelbrot uh when he was asked
about fractals he said
beautiful damn hard increasingly useful
that's fractals
and and i i'm really excited to see that
coming true that as as we move
we work in more and more systems that
we're finding more use for this
wonderful beautiful math
and i hope that it will continue to be
true and we'll see more and more uses
and so with that i'm michelle brush i
work at cerner
and i also you know big math geek and
i'm out of time
pretty much so what i'm going to do is
just say again come up to me later if
you want to talk about something i'll
show you
the little cube and thank you very much